[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
plaisir d'être avec vous je suis franck
maistre tout le monde nous parle
d'intelligence artificielle --six le 21e
siècle était aussi et surtout celui de
la révolution de l'intelligence humaine
la notion même d'intelligence est à la
croisée des chemins entre éducation
sociologie psychologie neurosciences
médecine génétique et bien d'autres
encore je vous propose ici et maintenant
une expérience unique en faisant table
rase de vos croyances et certitudes sur
l'intelligence
laissez vous ressentir aux sensations
physiques visualiser vos associations
d'idées ou encore accueillir les
émotions qui pourrait émerger à l'âge de
8 ans je suis devenu bête
il était en vacances avec mes parents
quand tout à coup je me suis mis à me
taper dessus point contrepoint incapable
de m'arrêter est conscient que je ne
contrôlais plus rien mon cerveau venait
de subir une hausse de l'activité
électrique entraînant une perturbation
temporaire de la communication entre mes
neurones
c'est ce qu'on appelle une crise
d'épilepsie
elle fut unique foudroyante et
provoquées par une combinaison de
facteurs
ma vie a basculé à ce moment là car
comme je vous disais je suis devenu bête
imaginez du jour au lendemain nul en
orthographe
alors que j'étais bon élève dyslexique
alors que je me voyais un grand orateur
politique et j'ai développé un
comportement agressif
c'était comme repartir de zéro mais aura
fallu six ans pour récupérer mes
facultés et arrêté l'anti épileptique
qui m'avait été prescrit six ans avec ma
mère sur le dos en permanence merci à
être parce que là vraiment jamais rien
lâché 6 ans d'efforts avec des séances
régulières dans ses pas logram et séance
hachée
sochaux nice ou encore du travail à la
maison x 2 que bien évidemment un petit
garçon de l'âge de 8 ans adore ce qui
m'apportait la persévérance et l'amour
de ma grand mère de ma mère et d'un ami
très cher qui sont rentrés dans ma vie à
ce moment là le travail et le plaisir
ce sont donc des deux piliers sur lequel
je me suis appuyé pour me réparer ces
deux piliers m'ont permis de récupérer
des facultés perdu d'en développer de
nouvelles d'eux surtout n'avoir jamais
cessé même bête de me considérer comme
intelligent oui vous avez bien entendu
même bête nous pouvons être intelligent
et de cette expérience j'ai acquis la
certitude profonde en moi que nous avons
tous des potentiels des intelligences
inexploitées et qu'il nous faut sortir
du cadre d'un croyances pour en voir
toutes leurs richesses
il est temps que l'intelligence humaine
face à révolution il est un sel de cette
révolution c'est de commencer par
arrêter de douter de nos croyances notre
intelligence pardon voyez comment c'est
fort arrêtons de dénigrer notre
intelligence et ce quels que soient les
faux départ les erreurs de parcours les
chocs qui peuvent nous amoindrit re
je vous propose ici maintenant un petit
sondage levée juste la main pour ceux
qui se sentiraient concernés qui parmi
vous se croit intelligent allait oser
soyez libres
parmi ceux qui ont levé la main qui est
capable de définir son intelligence à
dire d'en voir ses contours sa typicité
et on reste plus beaucoup à merci et
parmi vous qui est capable de dire qui
mobilise en permanence son intelligence
au quotidien dans sa vie professionnelle
ou personnelle
génial nous venons de le constater la
grande majorité d'entre nous vis
interagit travail sans avoir la moindre
idée de son authentique potentiel
individuel
soyez assurés que reconnaître vos
intelligence changera votre vie mais
vous faites quand on aborde
l'intelligence de quoi parle-t-on au 19e
siècle
francis galton cousin de charles darwin
associés intelligence et vitesse il a
étudié le temps de réaction de notre
cerveau à une simple information sur la
base de cette même méthodologie un
scientifique contemporain tennisman
suisse a analysé 15 études portant sur
les 150 dernières années
le résultat est clair nous avons
augmenté notre temps de réponse de 50
millisecondes
nous sommes donc devenus de plus en plus
lent soit potentiellement de moins en
moins intelligente et qu'elle en est il
du fameux test depuis les résultats sur
les 60 dernières années montrent une
augmentation considérable puisque nous
sommes passés de 30 sur 60 dans les
années 60 à 45 sur 60 aujourd'hui
deux bémols le paradoxe de fines et voix
et qui témoigne d'un résultat août la
courbe plafonne pire dans certains pays
comme en grande bretagne ou en france
des résultats baissent moins quatre
points en 2010 est sur les dix dernières
années le test du qi serait-il devenu
obsolète
pour moi il n'existe pas une échelle
unique d'évaluation de l'intelligence
alors j'ai creusé j'ai cherché d'autres
façons de réfléchi
j'ai trouvé howard d'un air un
professeur génial d'harvard d' qui
définit l'intelligence comme notre
capacité à résoudre des problèmes et à
produire des biens ayant une valeur dans
un contexte culturel et collectifs
précis il indique que les problèmes à
résoudre vont de l'invention de la fin
d'une histoire à l'anticipation d'un
math aux échecs en passant par le roi
comme otage d'un édredon et des biens à
produire d'une théorie scientifique à
une composition musicale en passant par
une campagne politique victorieuse des
choses très intéressantes dans cette
définition la notion de valeur
l'intelligence est sorti d'un simple
score sur une feuille est elle la
replace dans son utilité au vivant le
raccommodage d'un édredon on sort
l'intelligence de la pure activité
cérébrale et enfin nous avons tous
développé des capacités à résoudre des
problèmes et à produire des biens et
chacun à sa manière ce qui veut dire
deux choses nous sommes tous assurément
intelligent et potentiellement il ya
autant intelligence que d'individus
howard garner identifie huit types
d'intelligence pour ma part dans mon
travail et avec mon expérience
j'irais même jusqu'à 12 pour
l'intelligence les quatre en plus de
voir gerner c'est l'intelligence
émotionnelle pour moi vous avez un des
pères fondateurs qui aujourd'hui
président l'université yale
l'intelligence de créativité vous avez
des travaux ceux de réaction qui sortent
en début de cette année qui m'ont toute
la spécificité de l'intelligence de
créativité l'intelligence de la
différence c'est cette intelligence qui
nous permet de voir par exemple tout
potentiel des autistes et non pas leur
handicap et enfin l'intelligence du
coeur à ce que ces aides qui nous relie
à tous à notre humanité et donc aux
vivants
peut-être que certains d'entre vous se
sont reconnus dans une ou plusieurs
formes d'intelligence c'est la première
étape reconnaître ce qui se passe en
nous et là émergent
évidemment la question mais comment je
suis capable de reconnaître mais
intelligence écoutez vos émotions
ressentez et vos sensations pour
reconnaître vos intelligence parce que
oui nous vivons en permanence des
émotions des sensations liées à
l'interaction que nous avons avec le
reste du monde
tout l'enjeu est d'en extraire ces
petits est important pour soi pour
reconnaître ce qui se passe en nous aux
et accepter que j'étais devenu bête
c'était accepter de ressentir toute la
tristesse et la colère qu'il y avait en
moi mais aussi la honte
un petit garçon de l'âge de huit ans en
pays de victor hugo
croyez moi ça reste toujours intolérable
reconnaît
ce qui se passe en nous donc merci aux
émotions merci à la colère merci à la
tristesse mais elles nous permettent
aussi identifier là où on va
naturellement on l'a on peut se faire
plaisir
c'est la joie j'adore une autre
définition de l'intelligence et la
capacité à résoudre des problèmes avec
un minimum d'effort c'est possible
facile me direz vous pas si simple vous
répondrais ch parce que nous sommes
nombreux à avoir développé des
comportements qui nous coupent de nos
émotions
le jugement par exemple qui a un effet
castrateur on s'empêche d'être curieux à
soi et aussi aux autres ou la
suractivité
pas besoin de vous faire un dessin je
pense que vous ayez très bien de quoi je
parle et non sur l'activité par exemple
digital où on est beaucoup plus
connectée à notre smartphone canaux
simple émotion et la l'environnement
joue un rôle prépondérant
il est aussi important identifier ces
intelligences que de savoir dans quel
environnement en évolué il ya des
environnements qui sont bons pour soi et
des environnements qui sont toxiques
aussi pour soi et donc reconnaître son
environnement va nous permettre de voir
que là un environnement sain va jouer le
rôle de facilitateur
il va permettre d' incorporer notre
expérience pour valider qu'à cet endroit
là nous avons développé une forme
d'intelligence et de façon réitérative
nous allons reconnaître expérimenté en
conscience pour incorporer
et voir ainsi l'expérience enrichi à
nouveau et quand on arrive au point de
saturation au point d' équilibre entre
travail et plaisir
un seul conseil continuez d'être curieux
de vous même et là nous allons avoir une
nouvelle forme d'intelligence que nous
pourrions développer qui potentialise
ras la prochaine et moi dans tout ça
banquier ici ça vous parle
en tout cas ça parle de moi où j'ai
développer l'intelligence logico
mathématique par fidélité à mon père et
à mon grand père dans l'univers de la
banque
il y a huit ans j'ai passé un
assessments pour avoir un poste à plus
fortes responsabilités je les foires et
pourquoi pas ce qu'il pense à que je
n'aurais pas été suffisamment à l'écouté
j'ai été en colère parce que je savais
que c'était à l'antithèse de ce que
j'étais profondément mais aujourd'hui je
remercie cette colère parce que c'est
cette colère qui m'a permis de sortir de
la voie royale du banquier d'aller vers
des chemins de travers par exemple pour
attaquer une formation de psycho
praticiens ou encore d'accepter un
nouveau poste de directeur d'un centre
d'innovation et aujourd'hui je mets au
service des femmes et des hommes
entrepreneurs que j'accompagne mon
intelligence logico mathématique
interpersonnelles intra personnel et
comme pour vous montrer que c'est un
processus sans fin
ce nouveau poste m'a obligé d'aller
tester mon intelligence de créativité
oui parce qu'il m'a fallu
agence est un nouveau lieu créé prévoir
de nouveaux événements rencontrés des
développeurs des designers et croyez-moi
quand on est banquier on ne rencontre
pas forcément des développeurs et des
designers faire de ce lieu une
proposition unique pour oak à chaque
fois les gens qui viennent se disent là
ici c'est intéressant il se passe
quelque chose je suis donc devenu
créatif jusqu'où j'ai poussé cette
créativité jusqu'à créer une méthode qui
intègre les neurosciences en entreprise
pour accompagner l'innovation et les
projets et aujourd'hui je sens
profondément en moi que toutes les
intelligences inter agissent ensemble et
qu'elles sont interdépendantes les unes
des autres et nous avons tous une
responsabilité collective qui est de
transmettre nos expériences pour
enrichir cette des autres et voir ainsi
nos intelligences comme un bien commun
merci
[Applaudissements]